today we're going to be speaking with
graham wood who's a
journalist writes for the atlantic also
author of the book the way
of the strangers um really glad to have
you on graham looking forward to this
thanks for having me dave so let's talk
a little bit about the concept of a
failed state
there are those who have been
attributing the term failed state to the
united states
in the context of the failure to mount
a reasonable response to the coronavirus
pandemic
very high rate of per capita cases
and death others have been talking about
the u.s as a failed state in the context
of trump's failed leadership in the u.s
increasingly being pushed aside on
conversations of climate and and so many
others
the idea of a failed state and that we
had a sitting president
tried to subvert the will of the people
so brazenly as donald trump tried to
keep the
the the white house even despite losing
to joe biden uh what's your sense of
how accurate this term is and how we
should think about that well first of
all i think the term failed state
as you as you point out it's got a
diversity
of effects it's it's sometimes just a
state that doesn't exist it's sometimes
a state that is malevolent
sometimes a state that that um doesn't
do its job well and
i think of the of the three we've
probably seen most of
of of the last one but with touches of
the other ones
so when i think of other states that
have failed
um they're all of course horrible
humanitarian disasters
somalia probably being the most famous
example from the
last few decades and i don't see as
moving
in to that position what i do see
is enough institutions of government
that have broken down
that uh you could be forgiven for
thinking that
that the pressure tests just
exposed huge huge flaws
and shortcomings in government and
the the most worrying thing first of all
is that they exist and second of all
there seems to be no remedy for them
they don't seem to be getting any better
and there's
there's no impetus certainly with the
current administration
to do what i would say that the
necessary work
would be to correct them yeah a lot of
it is
failed uh failure to meet expectations
right the
uh when we talk about a failed state
it's not necessarily
some of the things you mentioned but
it's we might have imagined then those
who believe in american exceptionalism
might have imagined
we would have been one of the best
countries in dealing with the pandemic a
rich country with so many resources so
so maybe a lot of it is about the
failure to meet expectations
same applies to the democratic uh uh
thing as we might call it
uh with regard to the 2020 election just
not what people expected
yeah so i i think we can go beyond
politics too i mean
the tools that the world has used to
handle the pandemic
successfully where it's done so
successfully uh were largely american
creations i mean
american ingenuity created things like
pcr for example that has been deployed
at scale with great success in smaller
countries with fewer resources
than we in the united states have so you
start seeing
the the expectations just not not being
lived up to that's that's i think
the main thing i mean there's also
though the fact that the united states
has really never stopped thinking of
itself as uh
in in idealistic terms whereas other
countries i think have
have um been more cynical about their
role in the world
so you know it's not as likely i think
to find
say someone who's uh from the uk
thinking
that the the uk is going to be a a
beacon for hope
that the model of the uk is going to be
exported elsewhere
as americans we we inherit that that's
that's that's part of our legacy
and so we also see ourselves failing
to live up to not just our capacities
but our ideals that we we
tell ourselves and then to a large
extent tell other people to
you know i got very interesting phone
calls in the last couple of weeks
from since the election from british and
belgian viewers a a british and a
belgian viewer
and they said you know david in watching
the election
take place in the run-up to november 3rd
and and what happened
there and after it's really weird
to see people talking about our
democracy in a campaign
like a discussion of the concept of our
democracy in a campaign our democracy
being at risk
or an attack on democracy that it was
unusual to even see
that discussion and it would be unusual
in places like the uk and belgium and
maybe others
what's your thought about that yeah i
think to a lot of the world americans
look very naive
i mean we think that these stories we
tell ourselves
are true uh we we don't assume that
they're offered
in a purely cynical way um and
i think that's a good thing about the
united states and it's something that i
actually wish
other countries would um would do a bit
more of maybe with
with with the uh with
some revisions as i wish that we would
do with some revisions you know there's
there's so much discussion of the sins
of america
and those sins actually happened so yeah
we revise our idealism
on that basis but when a belgian hears
us talk about
what the importance is of american
democracy
if you're a belgian that there is no
current strain of belgian thought that
suggests that maybe the belgian model is
the savior
of mankind uh there's definitely a
living
version of american exceptionalism that
believes exactly that
so um somewhere in the middle is
probably the right right place but it
means that
the failure of the united states
politically
in public health is all that more
all that much more heartbreaking i think
to americans what is your
sense of where and how unrest
and maybe violence would would develop
um
there is speculation you know both sides
love to say the other side is really the
violent one
i believe that when you look at
political violence uh the
the groups that study this have found
that it really is
disproportionately from the right
against the left
but you know there's been speculation
about um
yesterday's milestone the certification
the voting of the electors could trigger
violence
or january 6th
or january 20th these different dates um
what do you what is your sense about
what we might expect and what might
really lead to
such violence yeah i mean my tendency
i'm sort of an empiricist i'm a reporter
i go places
and see things and work from there
rather than generalizing trends
and then making predictions from there
so i i'm guessing that
going forward we're more likely to see
things that are totally unforeseen
come up rather than than um things like
republicans stab in the back kind of
narratives for example
being the ones that that that define the
the unrest in the year to come so what
i'm most worried about
is uh various unforeseen things that
could blossom into much much more so you
take for example something like
george floyd there's plenty of examples
of police brutality of racism
that particular one i don't think any of
us could have predicted that it
would spark what it did and incidents
like that
will happen more and more it's it's
never been easier to take one incident
that may very well be illustrative
or emblematic or a good example
of a larger trend and then turn them
into something that
you could never have predicted what they
would would become so
whenever there is any kind of armed
protest whenever there is a face-off
between
militias say in an american city which
seems to happen
as a matter of course whenever there's
any kind of public demonstration
you have the possibility where there
will be a gun battle in america in an
american city
that could mean dozens of people killed
i hope that doesn't happen
but where does that start it starts with
one gunshot and
i'm worried that there might be
something that that that begins
in that totally unpredictable and even
almost random way uh and the effects of
that
could be uh could could be rippling and
enormous
yeah what you're really talking about is
the importance of
what nasim nicholas talib calls black
swans right these rare events which by
their nature are unpredictable
risk models don't account for them risk
models that say we are accounting for
really rare events don't
um talib kind of elaborates on this
further in his book fooled by randomness
it even takes
a important important role in his book
anti-fragile these are these are the
fundamentally difficult to
to predict events and that's what makes
it so difficult to answer these
questions
yeah that's right these are are
spontaneous events
uh and they are extremely contingent on
you know if it's a single gunshot that
erupts that that
that gun battle that i hypothesized
before
then it could be because that person
leaned on his gun the wrong way it could
be that he
he uh you know didn't have a good
breakfast that morning
that kind of thing is usually what what
causes to causes
events to be to be um kicked into motion
i mean if we were to look back a year
ago there are some things we could have
predicted
some things we couldn't have we could
have predicted that the president of the
united states
would display all the traits that he's
shown in the rest of his political life
those things yes but the very fact that
we
saw this failed pressure test of
of the regulatory and other apparatus of
the united states to the pandemic
probably not something that anybody um
you know had on the bingo card so
that kind of thing i think is much more
likely to define 2021
than uh anything that that could be
easily foreseen
i have this idea that i'm curious to get
your thoughts on
about there are competing forces
that sort of make it less likely that
you will see
mass rallies huge protests in the united
states to the level that they sort of
start
shutting down aspects of the economy or
cities or whatever the case may be and
it's
on the one hand you have the combination
of ready access to credit
and cheap stuff from china and other
countries
which keeps a lot of people just
comfortable enough
not to go out in protest because they'd
rather stay home and watch the game so
to speak and this is not
to diminish uh civic activism it's not
to pretend that everybody's in a
comfortable position but there's
there's a swath of of the population
that may be in a different economy
without ready access to chiefs
cheap stuff from china and without ready
access to credit with which to buy that
stuff
might be less comfortable and thus more
eager to go out and protest now on the
other hand you have this kind of
um forced precarity people who recognize
wait um if i take a day off to go
protest i could lose my job or at least
not get paid that day
and then my health insurance is in
question and then i don't know if i have
food for my kids
and so that disincentivizes going out to
to protest what do you think of that as
a systemic analysis
uh that maybe so i mean the the russian
revolution famously
might not have happened if the weather
hadn't permitted
certain you know crossing of the rivers
and by by
large groups of people so it's not um
it's not impossible that there would be
would be things like that that would be
equally um determinative
of whether people are willing to go out
and and be
um be political on mass um
there's also though again the the
relationship for example between the
protests that happened
this summer and the pandemic uh
i think is still un is misunderstood
underexplored
um they seem in some ways to have
nothing to do with each other
police violence is something that's
happened for a very long time the
pandemic
was it was almost like a short break
that people took from the pandemic
to deal with this urgent matter now
i think there's probably more to it than
that um
the effects on mass psychology
individual psychology of being pent up
of being prevented from seeing the faces
of other human beings
is immense and once that stops
i think a lot of things will actually
change they might not change in
predictable ways
but things like the politics of mass
gatherings
that could be one of the things that
that
turns out to to change a lot as a result
of
the coming of say a vaccine in terms of
the psychological
i've been thinking a lot about postcovid
i think that even when mathematically
things go back to what they were before
where
during flu season you have a higher risk
of catching the flu
and it's less deadly than coronavirus
but it's the same as before coronavirus
i think that there will be risks that
were always there
that people weren't maybe thinking of
and you may see
folks particularly in certain risk
categories
who just during flu season might want to
wear a mask or might stay home or
i think there's going to be sort of a
realignment as as a
flex as much as humans return to the
mean and go back to the way things were
i think that at least for for years
there are going to be aspects of this
with us
yeah i mean there's some just factual
knowledge that we have
that either didn't know before or we
didn't care about before
like the fact that that you know during
flu season you can possibly save
thousands and thousands of lives by
doing something like wearing a mask
every japanese person do that almost no
americans knew that so
that knowledge is with us for good what
i'm thinking more
are is i'm thinking more about
different types of psychological effects
i mean i i've had a a
a strange pandemic in that i was
uh i was isolated as we were all told to
be
for for months at a time i'm glad i did
that and then i've gone out and i've
reported
too so and i've moved from country to
country to
i've been traveling more than most
people this year
and have seen how the pandemic looks
from from place to place
and i would not have guessed from my
position of solitude in those first
months
how different the feeling in psychology
was
mass psychology was of going out and
experiencing places where the pandemic
hadn't hit as hard
so i i think we can be lulled into
thinking that that
um that nothing deeply has changed about
how we're looking at the world
um because it changes slowly and then
once
there's the the great pandemic jailbreak
because
the curve has been broken or the vaccine
has been distributed
then i think we'll emerge and we will
discover
with great surprise how different the
world has become
while we were locked away that's that's
what i'm actually mostly looking forward
to i think the world will be
uh we'll discover that the world
suddenly improves once we
are able to go out but the the fact of
change i have little doubt about
massive change yes absolutely um
absolutely agree we've been speaking
with graham wood
a journalist who writes for the atlantic
and is also author of the book
the way of the strangers so appreciate
your time today graham
it was a pleasure